[Music]  [Music]  yes come on what are you addressed yeah  I don't know what's going on what's  going on is you're supposed to be  guarding the boss's daughter not  screwing her I didn't sleep with her  no no I mean yes I slept with her many  times but me that wasn't me that was the  old me  I just got here like 20 seconds ago  really yeah and what happened to your  clothes  no oh would you believe me if I told you  I was sent here from the future get out  of your throat yeah we're gonna take  care of this comedian Lena you're gonna  give me the keys he car and some money  for gas who are you gonna wake up in the  hospital trust me I know how these  things play out oh because you're from  the future  no because of these  you